merci on va on va on va suivre tout ça
bien entendu c'est l'annonce du jour
Secret Story va faire son retour après
14 ans d'absence c'est donc officiel la
voix et de retour et le casting est
ouvert mais il c'était pas revenu déjà
sur
Av av une rumeur comme quoi ça allait
reprendre mais c'était pas revenu sur
TFX Gill verdezuse te non non mais
justement je réfléchissais que
venez à ma connaissance non christop
berand il il animé quoi bah ça an mais
dansg la suite ça avait été déplacé
parce que ça ne marchait plus mais il y
a pas eu d'interruption et de retour
cétait un programme qui
avaitéétait achevé sur 14 ans d'absence
donc TF1 officialisé dans un un
communiqué accompagné d'une vidéo le
retour de l'émission Secret Story
[Musique]
regardez
on me confirme bien c'est revenu sur TFX
Secret Story à un moment etc Christophe
beugran oui oui vous avez vous avez à
mon avis vous avez eu un petit un petit
un petit problème de mémoire tous ici t
la mais ça me fait plaisir de vous avoir
quand même non mais ça ça fait plaisir
de pouvoir compter sur vous donc dans
une interview accordée à méia plus hier
le président dans desmoles donc
Jean-Louis blot producteur historique de
secr story donc le en démol donc c'est
eux qui vont reproduire Secret Story
donc c'est enmol qui va qui va produire
et ça y est donc c'est officiel Secret
Story arrive ça arrive près quand ça y
est bah ils sont en train de préparer en
2024 le casting est ouvert donc l'année
prochaine ça revient ça y est en grande
pompe d'accord merci non mais
honnêtement c'est pour moi pour moi
c'est la meilleure téléréalité qui
existait d'ailleurs les scènes cultes
elles sont très nombreuses les
personnages qui aujourd'hui sont encore
très connus parce que il y a des gens
qui ont fait cette émission il y a déjà
des des dizaines quinzaines d'Ann anné
et qui sont aujourd'hui toujours suivis
énormément sur les réseaux ils font
encore partie de l'actualité donc c'est
pour moi la meilleure émission de
téléréalité donc c'est une très bonne
nouvelle que ça repren ça revient après
6 ans d'absence bien entendu c'était
donc sur TFX et 14 ans je crois sur TF1
voilà c'était était parvenu sur TF1
alors la première de Secret Story sa
date de 2007 a été présentée par
Benjamin Castaldi
regardez bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur
TF1 ça y est ça y est et c'est ce soir
c'est maintenant le lancement de
l'événement TF Secret
Story après toutes les plus foles
rumeurs entendu élu vous serez toute la
vérité rien que la vérité ce soir je
vous le jure vous connaîtrez enfin les
13 candidats six filles SEP garçons qui
vont vivre dans une maison de 900 m² et
surveillé 22h/ 24 par 50 caméras et
autant de micros
alors alors donc ça revient apparemment
je vous le dis j'ai eu mon Benji
aujourd'hui il m'en a pas du tout parlé
et je crois que Benjamin il ils l'ont
même pas ils l'ont même pas appelé pour
lui proposer ce serait qui qui animerait
Christophe beugrand a été reçu
auditionné il est pas exclu que ce soit
lui qui reprenne ah oui c'est lui qui le
faisait donc for exactement il était il
avait succédé à Benjamin ah oui il avait
été un peu bon le le le programme
c'était éteint avec lui il faut bien le
dire ça n'avait pas cartonné c'était pas
du tout é avec lui va faire un programme
sur TFX to on va voir s'il va pas
s'éteindre tu as fait un programme sur C
news il s'est éteint une semaine mais
c'est vrai non mais non mais voilà donc
donc Christophe beugrand il a pas
démérité sur TFX je suis désolé les gars
c'est sur sur quand tu mets un programme
sur TFX ou tu le mets sur TF1 c'est pas
la même croyait déjà plus on va dire
peut-être alors je vais te dire est-ce
que ça va ça va revenir en prime
time par avant ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que sec story je crois que CIT en
deux partie de soirée vous rendez compte
l'argent qu'il y avait à la télévision
parce que il faisait un prime time donc
normal et après fa sec auourdhu Imposs
Audi je va
E et qui va rester très tard il vont
faire sec story je suis S et et est-ce
que stor je pense ça va marcher sur sur
les le public jeune mais est-ce que ça
peut
rassembler assez téléspectateurs surtout
sur les primes on se pose la question
parce que c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
voilà même la star qui a bien marché ça
fait quoi 3 millions et demi 3 million 8
est-ce que alors qu'il a un spectacle
dans St est-ce que les prime de Secret
Story peuvent marcher oui je pense que
ça peut marcher en replay beaucoup parce
que maintenant les gens regardent
beaucoup plus en replay après en direct
en fait c'est que c'est des horair
auquel maintenant et puis les gens qui
ont regardé Secret Story et qui vont
avoir envie de regarder c'est maintenant
c'est ma génération et aux heures à
laquelle on regardait Secret Story
c'était au moment où on sortait de
l'école et aujourd'hui on fait d'autres
choses quoi et après au niveau des du
casting il va falloir qu'il soit très
fort parce que aujourd'hui les gens ont
beaucoup plus les codes de la
téléréalité que c'était le cas avant et
c'est c'est le problème que ça puiss
tomber dans les dérives de gens qui
cherchent à tout prix le bu c'est ça
c'est le problème maintenant dans ces
dans ces émissions alors Christophe
beogrand fait partie des personnes qui
on sont testé c'est pas encore lui qui a
été il éé auditionné ce serait le
vendredi
soir vendredi soir ou jeudi so il a une
certaine longueur d'avance je peux pas
vous dire là pour moi pour moi c'est pas
encore déterminé mais je suis le seul à
être affligé par le fait que TF1 avec
une force de frappe quand même
incroyable la plus grande chaîne
d'Europe pas longtemps ressort des vieux
pot star Secret
Story a la vérité qui comp nousou vous
dis
vérité voulez que je vous dis la vérité
la vérité qui compte ça fait entre 1
mlion et 1 mlion2 toutes les semaines
sur C8 s'il l'avait mis sur TF1
crois-moi il y a que la vérité qui
compte ça aurait fait 4 millions et demi
voire 5 millions de téléspectateurs en
prime et ça le aurait coûté beaucoup
moins cher que ça mais il il y a
peut-être un goût pour le revival
justement si c'est programme reviennent
c'est peut-être que les gens en fait en
fait il y a eu le test de la star
academmy la star academmy a marché donc
ils sont dit derrière on va faire Secret
Story moi si j'étais M6 je relancerai
derrière love story franchement
s on besoin c'est compliqué il faut voir
voir comment faut voir comment le faire
mais aujourd'hui il vaut mieux faire
love story qui coûte un peu d'argent que
la meilleure
photoit sec story c une sorte de love
story mais c'est vrai que les secrets ça
apporte tellement à
l'émission
S
foroditeit qui ont marqué notre
franchement alors saison il y a
nombreuses histoires d'amour qui sont
créé et si on devit reten ce serait
laquelle serait celle d'amie et ah
oui ou qu même de la
merde c'est meur-ce que tu as dit c'est
quand même de la merde pas du
tout secr bid en tout le monde le sait
mais c'est vrai
que franchement tu as raison mais les
secr arrêter que le mec moi je sais
comment ça se passe le mec il est arrivé
dans le bureau alors c'est quoi ton
secret bah mon secret je sais pas
j'arrive à j'arrive à mettre mon cou
derrière la tête bon tu sais quoi tu es
unaphrodite allez
barre-oi moi il m'avait appelé j'avais
eu un cou à l'époque et justement non
non justement il m'avait dit est-ce que
vous avez un secret donc moi j'ai
cherché moi j'ai trouvé un secret de
merde dit bah non moi j'ai dit bah je
suis uniaque trou truc un truc de merde
non mais j'avais pas de secret donc
voilà et ils m'ont dit bah non non on
cherche vraiment des vrais secrets enfin
ça avait l'air quand même d'être assez
sérieux ils m'ont pas proposé de me
rencontrer si j'avais pas de secret al P
vouis prendre par téléphone il pouvit
pas savoir Rapp la demande en mariage de
sa et amée bien
s regardez là je crois que il est temps
pour moi que je devienne un homme ton
homme
[Musique]
j'espère est-ce que tu veux devenir ma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ch
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
beau ça me rappelle gilet Fatou mais en
mieux c'est V ça rappelle gilet Fatou en
bien non mais c'est fou mais même ça
c'est bidon ici mais ils se sont séparés
juste
après secrs gen je suis bras droit de la
voix je suis le guide de la voix je suis
la VO c'est des
secrson veut c'est des vrais
secr
voil mais les gens s'attachai pas au
secret s'attach au personnag plein de
jeux quand même c'était inrigant demand
passimination franchement j'étais F de
ma génération il y a plein de gens qui
étaient totalement c'est pour ça alors
moi est-ce que que vous pense que ça va
marcher je POS la question ce qu'on aime
beaucoup c'est les Clash et le problème
aussi que j'ai aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec
la télé d'aujourd'hui et avec l'arcom
qui est très présent et les réseaux
sociaux qui sont beaucoup plus présents
qu'avant est-ce qu'il va pouvoir y avoir
des Clash comme il y avait avant ça je
peux vous dire ça fait pas de jours il y
a des signalements à l'arcom je
t'explique au bout de jours il disent
bon voilà donc si c'est pour voir des
mecs manger des dates franchement non
mais c'est vrai on a droit un énorme
clash rappelle dans la saison 6 entre
Kevin Virginie et Caroline c'est l'un
des plus gros clash de l'histoire de
Secret Story et je vous dis heureusement
qu'il y avait une vitre
regarde
heureusement il y a une
vitre alors moi je suis V pour te dire
de choses ah non non d'abord je vais
parler ah oui d'abord je vais parler
parce que la première fois tu as parlé
et j'ai pas pu ouvrir ma gueule alors
j'ai une seule chose à vous dire à tous
les deux je avais demandé une seule
chose Kevin une seule c'était de pas
venir ici avec elle c'était une seule
chose vous avez décidé de vous remettre
ensemble tant mieux pour vous je te
souhaite absolument tout le bonheur que
tu mérites avec lui mais c'est au plus
sincère de mon cœur tu as voulu prendre
les MI prends les miettes tu as attendu
pendant 3 ans j'en tu te tis tu me
laisses
parler tu fermes tu comprends ça vous
êtes venus tous les deux ici pour faire
quoi pour vous afficher vous vendez pas
assez de papier
dehors vous avez vu vous avez vu comme
ça vieill en fait parce que quand tu
vois ça comme disais ça tu l'as tous les
jours toute la
journée mais franchement moi je sais pas
à qui ils vont s'adresser avec cette
émission mais les jeunes je pense que
c'est5
franchement sur les réseaux sociaux sur
les réseaux sociaux il y a vachement de
de de petits moments comme ça qui
repassent et qui sont énormément
regardés énormément comment il a des TR
avec Amélie justement la belge avec son
ACC belge et tout les jeunes les jeunes
se réintéressent via TikTok à ces
séquences tout elle a dit le replay tout
à l'heure parce que les jeun il veulent
pas se taper les pubs et toi tu as tout
dit les petites séquences d'un minute
30 sur le digital ou sur une plateforme
ça peut marcher sur TF1 je pense pas que
c'était la peine de mettre mais ça va
marcher en replay replay plateform et
peti pastill sur insta une minute 30 2
minutes vous auriez vu ça sur sur une
plateforme vous C non mais non sur TF
ils vont s'en sortir avec le
replay sur cible ils vont être assez
haut voilà sur cible
siand vendredi soirants mais JIS quand
le soir ou ça ou ou capitaine Marl très
bien mais capitaine Marl ça va faire que
du plus de 60 donc forcément les jeunes
vont regarder secr story je dis
Gén V é il y a un autre class culte
c'est celui de Mélanie Anaïs lors de la
saison 10 de Secret Story la prod n'a
pas eu le temps de de réagir tellement
Anaïs était imprévisible regardez tu es
vraiment une hypocrite la vie de ma
mère je m'en bat les couilles ouais mais
jeis pas tu viens tu me parles normal et
après par derrière tu me casses qu tu
vas me rendre dans le cul je te rentrer
mon point dans le cul tu vas voir alors
non ça on ne fait pas ça calculatrice
est fatigué que
tu je te jure je me retiens là bah
retiens-toi ouis jeass
c'est bien
vabit
t'de a quoi ah il y a rien du tout pour
5000 € tu hypr oh là
là g frapper les gens comme toi put en
fait c'est toi la pire dans le couple
c'est pas possible qui si tu rapportes
des trucs rapport correctement au moins
d' ouais rapport correctement ETI de ce
qui te regarde
camé très très mal ça la séquence qu'on
vient de voir euh c'est vrai que après
je pense que il va avoir un problème en
prime time parce que si ça passe en
prime time ils vont faoir il y a des
gens qui me disent ils pourront pas ils
vont devoir diffuser en deuxième partie
de soirée parce que pour les Clash il
les scènes un petit peu hot donc si
c'est deuxième partie de soirée ça
devrait s'en sortir mais vous vous
rendez compte comme ça va coûter cher à
TF1 et c'est vrai que là ça va mais
c'est ce que vous disiez ça va durer 4h
3h ou c'est possible vous disz ça
possible ce clash là avec ces mots là
ces attitudes là je suis pas sûr
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement ça puisse
passer hein faut voir ça va êre
complié le top 3 des plus grosses
rigolades de Secret Story en 3è position
on a l'arrivée de Mélanie da Cruz et sa
pizza viande haché regardez cuisiner
finir le plat d'aliia pendant qu'il y en
a qui Mang d'accord mais après qu'on me
laisse pas bouffer bah tu sais quoi
classe c'est qui qui l'a préparé la
pizza qui TR Cu tu es malade ou quoi je
de la pizza viande haâchée je vais me
taper de la la pizza je sais pas quoi
j'ai même pas faim voilà je voulais de
la pizza viande hachée ils l'ont mangé
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire mais je ne
veux pas de pizza blanc de poulet vous
comprenez j'ai le droit de manger ce que
je veux ou
[Musique]
alors ça sent le vendredi soir hein je
pense je pense que ça va être le
vendredi soir les amis parce que le
jeudi soir TF1 sa fiction qui va revenir
quand il va avoir HP la fiction faut
voir faut voir après faut voir où le
jeudi soir en attendant le retour d'HPI
en tout cas ce sera pas le ce sera pas
ce sera vendredi ou jeudi ce sera pas je
pense le mardi paril vont remettre
colanta qui va renir le mardi voilà donc
ça sera ça sera le jeudi vendredi c'est
bien parce que les jeunes peuvent aussi
regarderoup aussi parce que ils peuvent
très bien faire un
access AC des
diff quen mais le problème de la
quotidienne ch c'est que les feuilletons
TF March très bien peut-être qu'il
ferait une quotidienne sur TFX je pense
ou ou sur voilà et sur TMC il faudrait
qu'il la démarre très tôt ou bien qu'il
la fasse très tôt sur TF1 peut-être en
After School à 17h15 avant les lesons
peut-être une quotidienne à 17h15 sur TF
jus 18 ou ouis sortant de l'É non ou à
l'époque mais là je pense qu'ils vont la
mettre à 17h15 avant avant demain vous
appartient
et aprèsdemain
j'ai en seconde position on a Rachel
lein Trapani qui a eu le secret le plus
court de l'histoire des secrets cétait
incroyableque
bonsoir alors je vous rappelle que je
vous rappelle que que Ros n'estutre que
Rachel Miss France 2007 et qu'elle doit
dissimuler aux autres évidemment ça
c'estité son titre et ce n'est pas une
candidate c'est c'est que pour le fun et
pour la blague mais pour l'instant
personne ne l'a reconnu en même temps
faut dire
qu'on temp par
connaiss Rachel lein elle dit Rachel
elle a dit
ah bah ce qui est sûr la c'est que le le
secret il a fait long feu
hein ah ouais le secret le secret il a
fait long feu incroable le secret mais
très très vite et en première position
on a Sabrina de la saison 7 qui a des
petites difficultés avec la langue
française regardez quand à Sabrina le
micro lui donne envie de prendre son pi
la perchette vers toi en la prenant par
le pied non pas avec le pied par le pied
de la perchette par le pied voilà mais
non voilà d'où l'expression de papier
bonœil voilà donc Secret Story de retour
sur TF1 euh les mais quand parce que le
4 novembre la starac donc c'est non non
non ça va arriver après ça ça va arriver
je pense au printemps ils ouvre le
casting là ouais ça va arriver au
printemps je pense printemps voir l'été
ça a toujours marché quand c'était
plutôt l'été plutôt le Printemps
Été ce sera par là il vont recevoir
plein de candidatur à mon avis
oui qui aurait envie de le faire ici
Moon non faut être anonyme et puis moi
je je ferai pas non jamais non c'est
vrai ouais et non mais par contre enfin
en vrai si j'avais su que ça all
repartir je pense que c'est l'une des
seules télés que j'aurais pu aimé faire
ah oui ouais et l'île de la tentation
parce que vous m'en avez parlé moi je
veux bien l'Î de la tentation la
tentation tu fis quoi toi lui il ferait
des tentateur ça veut
dire c'est pas tentateur c'est un mec
qui va t'aider à ne pas être tenté aller
nager boire des boire des cocktails
quirait s'enfermer dans un vous vous le
feriez vous aujourd'hui non vous ariez
pu faire mon secret voilà on sait pas et
votre secret vous êtes en couple avec
une star ah bah franchement ça aurait
été un
secr à 23 ans franchement je l'aurais
fait par par là je te parle là là
maintenant à 35 B on sait pas
franchement je pense que j'aurais envie
mais je pense que je serai nula plus
gros parce que je suis pas assez j'ai
j'ai plus le temps de supporter des des
gens des gens qui font qui prennent les
micrro avec les pieds et tout j'aurais
pas je supporterai pas donc au bout de
15 candidat je mett un câble au bout de
15 jours et puis j'en verrai tout péter
et ça pass non parce que je me barreris
du coup mais bon ou mais la production
aimerait ça ah ouais t secret é for sec
PARP pas de secret tu vois maintenant
mon secret jeai donné ici je vous don à
vous tu on le savait avant arrête ah non
non je l'avais donné sur le plateau sur
un plateau ah c'est vrai tu l'as donné
sur un plateau ouais mais si au plateau
de sur le plateau de people mais ouais
ah a bien sûr vous avez eu l'exclusivité
attends moi je donne tout pour vous he
c'est pour elle me sou des conneries
cellelà aussi elle me sou des conneries
calme-toi s'il te plaît calme-toi les
chéris je voudrais vous parler d'